[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma penso
[Musica]
eccomi qua intanto benvenuto a tutti
partiamo dalla prima cosa che cos'è il
parkour il parkour e l'arte del
movimento quindi di solito come avete
appena visto questo video siete abituati
a sentire chissà quali notizie sul
parkour mille ragazzi che saltano dal
the dei tetti più assoluti più strani
con mille metri di vuoto sotto
chissà perché beh innanzitutto partiamo
dal presupposto che come detto prima e
movimento quindi tutto e parkour
tutto ciò che noi facciamo da camminare
correre arrampicarci e molto
semplicemente abbassarsi quadrupedi a
tutto questo e parkour
ora che benefici possiamo trarre dal
parco stesso
beh sono molteplici intanto partiamo
dalla parte fisica
quindi partiamo da un'altra cosa che
tutti noi abbiamo fatto parkour una
volta nella vita
cioè quando eravamo molto piccoli e
saltavamo da una parte all'altra del
divano sarà applicavamo per casa
buttando mille scaffali a terra i
genitori ci lanciavano sbatte addosso a
una roba assurda e giocavamo al gioco
the floor e slava per terra celava
quindi devo stare in un punto in cui
sono in alto senza toccare per terra ora
mi chiedo quando abbiamo smesso di
muoverci tutti noi a un certo punto
crescendo abbiamo smesso di muoverci ci
siamo fatti ingannare dal tranello casa
divano letto scale sedia lavoro eletto
per dormire
quindi il concetto è perché abbiamo
smesso non era più divertente
i nostri amici ci prendevano in giro
perché a 14 anni ancora arrampicavamo
sugli alberi
beh questo sta a voi chiedervelo quello
che dovete sapere e che muoversi
divertente e tutti noi siamo in grado di
farlo
e importante capire che non è una cosa
strana
non è una cosa come mi è successo
un paio di mesi fa con un nemico mentre
mi allenavo nel parco una persona si
avvicina ha detto ma siete di campagna
vero no stiamo allenando però mettetevi
in gioco
sentitevi a vostro agio sperimentate ora
quali sono i benefici fisici
beh intanto doveva pensare che
sviluppiamo controllo potenza tecnica la
potenza senza controllo non è nulla il
controllo senza tecnica non è nulla
molto semplicemente per compiere un
salto ho bisogno di avere la forza nelle
gambe o bisogna avere il controllo per
poter fare questo e non fare questo ho
bisogno di avere la tecnica necessaria
per poter rilevare in alto e questa è la
parte fondamentale
queste sono le abilità che noi abbiamo a
disposizione di base da quando lasciamo
che sono saltare correre arrampicarsi
cadere spingere e tirare ce ne sono
altre ma queste sono le fondamentali che
utilizziamo e abbiamo modo di
utilizzarle tutti i giorni sono abilità
che ci possono servire appunto in
qualsiasi tipo di situazione che sia
quotidiana o no di base il parkour nasce
per affrontare le situazioni più estreme
quindi poi può essere utile ai vigili
del fuoco militari e sono situazioni
estreme situazione di salvataggio anche
in situazioni giornaliere come possono
essere c'è un terremoto devo uscire da
qua molto rapidamente sono bloccato al
quarto piano c'è un incendio di sotto
sono cose estreme certo però possono
capitare
e in questo caso attraverso il parkour
avrete la prontezza per affrontarle
parliamo di prontezza e riflessi
attraverso il parkour sviluppiamo tutto
ciò che riguarda per poter far fronte a
qualsiasi tipo di imprevisto appunto
attraverso la nostra prontezza fisica e
mentale
inoltre nel 2019 il parkour è un ottimo
modo per tenersi in forma per
sperimentare tutto ciò che può fare il
nostro corpo e per perché no aumentare
la
performance di un altro sport molto
spesso mi capita di collaborare con
motociclisti che ovviamente cadono
mentre sono in gara capita di cadere
capita di prendere una curva male devono
sapere come salvarsi
mi è capitato di lavorare con
professionisti dell'atletica leggera
mi è capitato di lavorare con persone
atleti di alto livello che fanno thai
boxe tutte persone che sono accomunate
da una cosa il parkour è una disciplina
completa che può donare tanto a livello
di performance anche per altre
discipline
ora scopriamo la nostra città
questo è un argomento molto interessante
perché dovete pensare che voi camminate
ogni giorno per la nostra città
guardate gli stessi vicoli le stesse
mura gli stessi gradini e non vedete
niente io ci vedo un sacco di cose come
avete visto qui è bastato ben poco per
muovermi servizio inserito un mezzo
gradino è una situazione direi statica e
piana niente di più andando per la città
camminando per la città
avrò modo di scoprire un sacco di cose
nuove
potrò vedere una via in un'ottica
differente un'ottica nuova posso godermi
la mia città non è più ci passo davanti
non posso più davanti a questa strada
così tanto per devo andare al lavoro e
ciao sono pronto e mi metto in gioco
vedendo un muretto davanti all'altro non
è più un muretto davanti all'altro ma
diventa un movimento questo è un
concetto molto importante che
approfondiamo attraverso questo le
strutture che noi utilizziamo si
chiamano spot nel gergo dei tracciatori
del di chi pratica parkour e molto
spesso sono strutture brutali stick e di
architettura brutali stica sono
strutture che risiedono di solito nella
periferia della città o addirittura in
zone degradate e malfamate ora chi
pratica parkour all'interno della
comunità vige il rispetto e l'educazione
innanzitutto dovrà pensare al fatto che
se io devo allenarmi qui questo deve
essere un luogo idoneo
per potermi permettere di allenarmi in
sicurezza e con totale tranquillità
quindi molto spesso ne col passare degli
anni mi è capitato di dover più volte
pulire i luoghi in cui mi alleno da
siringhe cocci bottiglie rotte sono
tutte cose che sembreranno futili ma in
realtà
diamo una mano alla città e anche voi
stessi allenandovi riscoprendo la vostra
città ci tenete di più perché terrete al
vostro luogo di allenamento diventerà
sacro perché lo volete tenere così per
tanto tempo per poterlo utilizzare più
tempo possibile
difatti passiamo al prossimo punto che
la riscoperta e la valorizzazione di
questi posti come possiamo fare per
rendere questi posti migliori
ora madrid copenaghen hanno ciascuno di
queste città una decina di parkour park
allora disposizione sono strutture
artificiali messe in zone che prima
erano malfamate di degrado continuo e ii
grado totale sociale
il giovane magari piazze di spaccio e
periferie zone non utilizzate saranno
prese e trasformate in luoghi idonei per
la pratica del parkour e sono diventate
nuove letteralmente luoghi pieni di vita
ora che benefici porta questa disciplina
a livello psicologico a livello fisico
l'ho detto impariamo appunto a
controllare meglio il nostro corpo a
sfruttarlo al massimo ma livello
psicologico non è che appunto come detto
prima prendo salto e wow sì l'ho fatto
no per superare l'ostacolo con il corpo
prima devo superarlo con la mente questa
la cosa molto importante la mente prima
di fare un movimento devo pensare devo
visualizzare nella mia mente me stesso
mentre sto per partire mentre sono in
aria
e mentre terra ok queste sono tutte cose
che devo fare prima di saltare e devo
anche visualizzare ogni minimo errore
che posso fare come può essere mettere
la mano più avanti mettere il piede più
indietro scivolare cadere sono tutte
cose che mi devo
immaginare prima del salto stesso questo
importante perché per l'impatto
psicologico e l'impatto psicologico che
abbiamo è abnorme cambia letteralmente
la concezione che su me stesso
innanzitutto mi dona più alto
consapevolezza mi permette di sviluppare
uno spirito autocritico e oggettivo
quindi posso permettermi di capirmi
meglio di vedere quali sono i miei
limiti ed eventualmente superarli una
cosa importante da dire e farsi una
domanda che sono in grado di compiere
questo salto posso farlo o la capacità
fisica e mentale per affrontarlo adesso
rispondere correttamente a questa
domanda inizia ad essere serio il gioco
mi rendo conto di ciò che posso fare e
questo cambia totalmente la mia
percezione di me stesso
creare schemi motori di movimento
universali in età educativa una delle
discipline più complete poiché va a
lavorare su tutti gli schemi motori in
versari di base generici e il parkour
proprio perché non stiamo affinando
abilità specifiche non stiamo parlando
di tirare un calcio una palla non stiamo
parlando di giocare a tennis ed è una
vita specifica una cosa specifica che
serve solamente a quel unico sport
stiamo parlando di muoversi di rotolare
di arrampicarsi di imparare a cadere di
imparare a controllare noi stessi questo
per i bambini ha un impatto fondamentale
non solo a livello fisico ma anche a
livello psicologico perché permette di
capirsi permette di essere oggettivi con
se stessi e sviluppa appunto in giovane
età uno spirito di conservazione
posso farlo non posso farlo non lo
faccio che questo porta un'altra cosa
importante che ogni percorso e personale
non si tratta di competizione ma di
sfidare se stessi il parkour è uno sport
individuale ma di gruppo non competitivo
che cosa significa è una disciplina
nella quale io metto la prova me stesso
e soltanto
me stesso perché è una disciplina nella
quale non è la regola che plasma lo
sport ma mai lo sport che plasma il mio
corpo
quindi perciò io con la mia anatomia e
con la mia fisicità farò delle cose
totalmente diverse da lei da lei e da
lei perché perché siete differenti da me
quindi ciò che io faccio voi lo farete
in un altro modo se per me scendere da
qui mi basta un salto mortale e voi lo
farete con un gradino con un passo
essendo tutto ciò e personale quindi non
dovete fare quello che faccio io
ma quello che fate voi e per i bambini è
fondamentale perché non li mette in una
condizione psicologica del devo essere
il migliore devo battere tutti no devo
sfidare me stesso devo essere devo
capirmi se sono in grado di farlo e
perciò sviluppa un forte senso di
comunità ora vi lascio con un paio di
curiosità visto che come detto il
parkour e si universale e dovremmo
provarlo tutti dovremmo continuare a
muoverci ma capiamo un paio di cose sul
nostro corpo bruce lee con un calcio ha
fatto toccare il soffitto ad un sacco di
sabbia di 135 kg il soffitto stava più
meno a questa altezza qua bus vi era
auto così ok è una cosa assurda e lui è
un essere umano
alex honnold è ultimamente è stato molto
gettonato proprio per il fatto che ha
fatto questa scalata praticamente
impossibile prima di lui infisso la
scalata free riders in fissolo cioè
senza agganci senza nessun gancio di
sicurezza l'ha fatto lui con le sue mani
per 900 metri di altezza in linea retta
ultimo usain bolt 100 metri in 9 secondi
e 58 questo per farvi capire che voi non
vi rendete conto chi siete non vi
rendete conto della vostra potenza e del
vostro corpo
siamo tutti seduti camminiamo ci
muoviamo
e andiamo a dormire vi lascio con questo
dubbio quando andate a casa chiedetevi
sono in grado di muovermi diversamente e
la risposta vedrete sarà sì grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]